(upbeat music)
(air whooshing)
- I'm Tina Hesman-Saey.
I'm a Senior Writer at
Science News Magazine,
and I cover Molecular Biology.
- And I'm Erin Garcia de Jesús,
a General Assignment
Reporter at Science News,
but since January of 2020,
Tina and I have mostly been covering
the coronavirus and Covid-19.
- We are here because
Science News is turning 100,
and as part of our centennial celebration,
we're talking to scientists about
some big ideas in their fields.
We have with us now four experts,
four scientists whose research
is helping us learn to
combat the coronavirus,
and I'll let them introduce themselves.
- Hi, I'm Mark Denison.
I'm a professor of Pediatrics
at Vanderbilt University Medical Center
in Nashville, Tennessee,
and I have been studying
coronavirus since,
I guess since 1984,
mostly focusing on their
replication targets
and more recently on antivirals.
- Hi, my name is Akiko Iwasaki.
I'm a professor of Immunobiology
at the Yale University School of medicine.
I'm also an investigator
of the Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
My lab studies antiviral immunity.
Prior to studying SARS-CoV-2,
we were studying different
viruses including,
herpes simplex virus, influenza,
Zika, rhinovirus, and others.
And since March of 2020,
we pivoted to studying SARS-CoV-2
infection and immunity.
- Hi, my name is David Martinez,
I'm a Postdoctoral
Scholar in the Baric lab
at the University of North Carolina.
In addition to that, I
am a Hannah Gray Fellow:
The Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
And prior to Covid-19,
then I had also studied viral immunity
to a number of different
viruses including HIV,
and Dengue virus as a Flavivirus model.
And at the start of the Covid-19 epidemic,
then our lab rapidly shifted our focus
to this novel coronavirus,
and we've been studying
the immunity to SARS-CoV-2
and even SARS related viruses
and just the greater beta
coronavirus genus ever since.
- Hi, I'm Kanta Subbarao.
I'm the Director of a
WHO collaborating Center
for Reference and Research on Influenza
in Melbourne, Australia.
And I'm the professor
in the Department of
Microbiology and Immunology
at the University of Melbourne.
I was previously at
the NIH for many years.
I've worked on influenza
for most my career,
and started working on SARS actually
with the great introduction
by Mark Denison back in 2002,
when I was at the NIH
and we had a very active SARS
program for about five years
working with the Baric Lab and with Mark.
And about five years
ago, I moved to Australia
where I primarily work on influenza.
But of course since the
emergence of SARS-CoV-2,
we've been looking on SARS 2 as well.
- Fantastic.
Thanks all of you
for those great
introductions of yourselves.
We're so excited to learn
and hear what you guys have to say today.
Akiko, our first question
is actually for you.
So you mentioned that before the pandemic,
you were not working on coronaviruses,
you pivoted in March, 2020.
And then I was wondering if
you could tell us a little bit
about what that was like
to pivot your research.
- Yeah, so this was quite
abrupt, as you can imagine.
Until like, as I said, March of 2020,
we were working on a
variety of different viruses
and also cancer immunology
and everyone was doing their own thing.
And of course the school was shut down
for research other than
those that are dedicated
to studying SARS-CoV-2.
And of course as an viral immunologist,
I was very motivated to
study this new corona virus
and trying to understand
the immune responses
that are happening in the patients.
And so we set up a biorepository
called Impact Yale,
where we would collect
longitudinal biospecimen
from patients in the hospital.
And that's how we sort of started to study
immune responses as they
happen in the patients.
And every day was an excitement
because we learned, all kinds
of things on a daily basis.
And at the same time it was very scary
because we didn't have
a vaccine at the time.
I wanted to make sure
my lab members are safe.
We took every precaution we can,
and thankfully none of us got infected,
but it was also a scary time for everyone.
- Well, Mark,
you obviously were studying coronaviruses
and you mentioned that
you've been working on
some antivirals.
Maybe you can talk a little bit about
how we have developed treatments
against the coronavirus
and where you see that going next.
- Oh, let's see, this is,
what do we have, like 12 hours,
is that what we have here?
(Tina laughs)
Well, our focus has really
been on the viral polymerase
and on the novel
proofreading extra nuclease
the coronaviruses in code,
which was really first
described in a virus infection
in my lab, back in 2007.
And that had sort of led me to
the interacting with other scientists,
and particularly polymerase biologists,
like Olve Peersen at Colorado State,
and Craig Cameron, who was
at Penn State at the time
and saying up,
because this enzyme seemed
to be knocking out viral,
the capacity of nucleoside
analogs to inhibit coronaviruses,
we wanted to try to find
compounds that would work
just really biochemically
or in genetically,
to really inhibit the virus replication.
So we had been really working on
fundamental principles of replication
and starting in around 2013,
we established our
collaboration with Gilead
and dealt with our long-term
collaboration with UNC.
And when we discovered that
this compound which we didn't know about
what it was at first was,
'cause we were working
blindly was Remdesivir,
and showed that this inhibited
the virus dramatically.
We then really pivoted
back starting in 2014,
to thinking about the capacity of these
to actually inhibit coronaviruses broadly.
We were interested at the time,
of course in MERS and using
our model viruses as well,
and SARS.
And so SARS, Covid, and then MERS,
in working at these and showing this.
And I think our enthusiasm just
really sort of grew and grew
as this first Remdesivir
and then the drug EIDD 1931
that became Molnupiravir
both showed this really
impressive dramatic capacity
to bypass this proofreading function
inhibit through virus replication.
I started learning what I
called learning drug development
as the second language late in life
where I wasn't very smart,
but I was really enthusiastic.
And we were also seeing the
capacity of these viruses,
of other bad viruses, et
cetera, to infect human cells.
So we started sort of pounding the drum
and standing up on the
street corner and preaching
that pandemics were coming,
and that we needed to
be prepared for them.
And so we were really,
just positioned us to be able to do that
and publishing our work
right before this started,
I think was just,
like it's unusual to call it serendipity
in the face of a pandemic,
but we're grateful that we
were in a position to do that.
So I think where we're going is,
right now obviously the
NIH and the whole world
is really interested in
this issue of particular
orally available antivirals
targeting multiple different targets
that can be broadly
active against coronaviruses.
At least the virus, the
family of coronaviruses,
if not more broadly against
other viruses as well.
So I think this renewed emphasis
and sort of this dramatic
focus around antivirals
is important because I
think we're seeing that,
as good as the vaccines are going to be,
we're still going to have
people who are at risk,
people who are immunocompromised,
people who need either prophylaxis
or they need treatment.
And that's something
that we're very excited
to continue to try to probe.
- Right. And so, I mean, there's been,
obviously Remdesivir is now approved
for treating Covid-19 for
people who are in the hospital,
and molnupiravir,
(Mark and Tina laughing)
- Molnupiravir.
- Molnupiravir, which I learned recently
is named for Thor's hammer.
- Well that's maybe apocryphal,
but that's what I was
told by one of the people
who developed it.
Mjölnir is Thor's hammer.
So that's where I heard it came.
- Right. So anyway,
that has recently had
some encouraging results
in clinical trials
for people who have been newly diagnosed.
- Mm-hmm.
- Why didn't we have
these antivirals before?
I mean, we've had
coronaviruses around forever.
- Well, I don't know that
there was more than one or two
funded programs in the world
working on coronavirus
antivirals before the pandemic.
And maybe we may have been the
only one in the United States
that I'm aware of that was
focused specifically on that.
I think part of it is because
antivirals are fundamentally difficult.
They're more difficult than vaccines.
So apologies to vaccinologists.
And the reason for that
is because viruses,
you can work out, a vaccine
to work outside of the cell.
An antiviral has to work inside of a cell
since viruses are obligate
intracellular parasites,
and they use host cell mechanism.
So anything you do with an antiviral
fundamentally is going to be
targeting the inside of a cell
and mechanisms that may be
common to the cell and the virus.
So, and also viruses are
exceptionally good at evading these
and finding something
that can damage the virus
without damaging the cell
is profoundly challenging.
I think maybe a final answer
is because there had never been
sort of a Manhattan project type approach
where everybody in the world
was looking at all their compounds,
was really willing to target this,
and that the resources
were brought to bear,
to bring immunologists, animal model,
geneticists, virologists,
biochemists, structural biologists,
evolutionary biologists,
together to try to understand quickly,
do we have targets that could work
and how do we develop those rapidly?
- Right.
Well, I want to switch over
and talk to Kanta a little bit about,
you know, this is a pandemic it's global,
and you're in Australia on
the other side of the world,
from the rest of us who
are in the United States.
Can you tell us a little bit about
what the experience has
been like in Australia
and for the rest of the world,
because you've been one of the people
who have been monitoring
the spread of the virus
and, you know, what are you seeing,
especially in terms of variants
and in what we can expect
out of this coronavirus.
- Sure.
I mean, I think that the
experience of the pandemic
has been very different in
different parts of the world.
Australia is a huge island,
and they closed their borders very early.
We closed our borders in February
of last year, completely.
So there was no further,
there was very little introduction
of the virus into Australia
and the same was true in
New Zealand, in Taiwan,
and Hong Kong, Singapore,
a lot of countries closed their borders.
So their experience of the pandemic
is really quite different
from what the US, the
UK, Europe and so on saw.
What we also did in Australia
was they instituted a
mandatory two week quarantine
for anybody returning to the country,
or coming into the country.
So that two week period
was actually long enough
to essentially capture any
infection that was brought in.
So seeding of the community
just wasn't happening very much.
That did happen when we had breakdowns
in the hotel quarantine
system, which did happen,
but we've had,
you know, we were really protected
through the first year and
something of this pandemic.
However, the Delta variant
has really changed all of that
because it is far more infectious.
And I don't know if it's
partly pandemic fatigue,
Australians have been
incredibly compliant.
I must say having spent most
of my adult life in America,
it's, you know, wearing a mask
was just not a political statement.
It was just done because
we were asked to do it,
and people were very compliant
with all of the restrictions.
So the country did very well.
Unfortunately now of
course we're dealing with
the fact that, you know, Delta
is here and it's spreading.
We're dealing with the fact that Australia
got a little complacent
and instituted
and actually deployed
vaccine rather slowly.
So we were pretty late
to the party for vaccines
and only now are really catching up.
So now we've overtaken the United States
in the number that are fully vaccinated.
And again, maybe it's the fact that
Aussies are a little more compliant,
but in many parts of the
country, more than 80%,
well over 80% of the population
has had their first dose,
and will get their second dose
within the next few weeks.
So I think we will reach,
and Canberra which is
the country's capital
has over 99% of first vaccination.
So they will be the most vaccinated city
in the world probably soon.
So, you know, it's been quite different
and it's been a little
heartbreaking for me to watch
the pandemic transpire in the US.
I worked for the us government
for most of my adult life,
and it's been really
quite devastating to watch
the size of the pandemic
and the fact that,
there was such a breakdown
in the support for public
health over the years,
that essentially this pandemic
was such a full-blown event
in the United States.
And even now when the numbers
are coming under control,
it's still far greater than
Australia has ever seen
through the whole pandemic.
So in a sense, you know, sitting far away,
it's been a bit of a mixed bag of
how I feel about it.
I mean, a lot of people here say,
"Oh, aren't you just so glad you're here?"
And I think, no. Everybody I
know is in America (laughs).
And I, you know, it's
very hard to be far away.
My family is there.
So it's hard to be far away
and observe this from a distance.
But on the other hand, you
know, in terms of science,
it's been amazing.
And, you know,
I spent huge number of my nighttime hours
on zoom calls and phone calls,
and the progress of science has been,
you know, just breathtaking.
- Yeah. Kanta, you
mentioned the Delta variant.
I'm curious what your thoughts are about,
you know, things were looking better
before the Delta variant came.
There were other variants as well
that people were concerned about.
Like, what are your thoughts
on how things would have gone
had that like, particularly
the Delta variant not
(indistinct)
- So that's a good question.
I mean, it's a hypothetical
because of course the Delta
variant is very much here
and has taken over all over the world.
And I don't think it's going
to be the last variant we see.
I think we will see
additional variants emerge.
And I think the reason
we're seeing variants
is because of the burden of infection
in the population around the world.
And we could talk about vaccine equity,
and third doses and so on,
but until we vaccinate more of the world,
we're going to see infections
in unvaccinated people
and the emergence of variants.
So, without the Delta variant,
the vaccines were looking fantastic.
And they continue to do very well
in protection against severe disease.
So if the initial goal,
and the initial goal of vaccination
was to prevent severe illness and death,
and to protect our healthcare systems.
And they've done very well with that,
even with the Delta variant.
Now, I think if the Beta
variant had actually taken off
and spread around the world,
we would have been an even worse trouble
because the Beta variant actually
is less well inhibited
by the antibody elicited by
the original Wuhan strain.
Against the Delta variant
I think the big issue
is that it is highly infectious,
and that even people
that are fully vaccinated
can get infected.
Now, I think it is not entirely clear yet
how much a fully vaccinated person
who gets infected with the Delta variant,
what is the risk of them
actually spreading it
to other fully vaccinated people?
I think that is a piece
of data we don't have yet.
We do know that vaccine induced immunity,
the antibody titers
are dropping with time.
We know that the Delta variant
is very fit and is spreading.
We also know the fully vaccinated people
can get infected with the Delta variant,
and they can shed virus at least by PCR
at a similar note as
an unvaccinated person.
But the bit of data that I don't see yet
is how many people,
how many fully vaccinated people,
a fully vaccinated person can infect.
So I think our hope is to actually
get the level of
vaccination up in the world
so that we can drive down some
of this burden of infection.
- Speaking of vaccines and variants,
this brings me to David.
You and your colleagues are working on,
like, next generation vaccines,
thinking about the future of the world
where we have lots of different variants,
or even other emerging coronaviruses
and working on something that
could tackle all of those
in a universal coronavirus vaccine.
What do you think have we learned
about the potential for
these types of shots
from your work?
- Yeah, so I think so far based
on all the data we've seen,
then achieving at least
a more broad vaccine,
at least against the
cousins of SARS-CoV-2,
might be a more readily
achievable thing to do.
So we've been able to at
least pre-clinically develop
vaccine concepts against
SARS related viruses,
including SARS-CoV-2 and
the critical variants
such as the Beta variant
that Kanta mentioned,
that is relatively more
neutralization resistant
compared to other variants.
So in terms of the broad spectrum vaccines
against the SARS related
viruses or the Sarbecoviruses,
then I think that might be
a easier target to achieve.
So we have a couple of
different vaccine concepts
that we've been involved with.
And so far,
both of those concepts appear to be
highly protective against
a number of different of
those viral infections.
I think moving forward, what
will be a more difficult target
to hit will be a more broad,
or a Beta coronavirus
vaccine, for example,
that not only covers this
SARS related viruses,
but also includes for example,
group 2c coronaviruses,
which include MERS, or even
the common cold coronaviruses.
- So you mean we might not
have to have colds anymore?
- That would be ideal.
And that of course remains
an aspirational goal.
But I think moving forward,
that is certainly where
we would all like to get
in terms of
developing a Beta coronavirus
widely protective vaccine
that could not only
prevent the infection from SARS-CoV-2,
but also more distant coronaviruses.
But of course,
that is currently being
tested preclinically.
So we don't yet know if
that'll be possible in humans.
- Can you talk a little bit about
what makes these universal
vaccines different
from the ones that we have
now against the coronavirus?
I mean, most of them are directed
against the spike protein,
or they are killed whole viruses.
Is that kind of approach you're taking,
like you get a spike protein
that is one size fits all,
or are you doing a
different type of approach?
- So a number of different
approaches are being tried.
We've been involved in
at least two of them.
And one of the approaches that
we've been primarily involved in,
is actually expanding
the breadth of the spike
by admixing the different
immunogenic domains,
so the NTD, the RBD, and the S2
in generating chimeric spikes,
and then with the advent
of the mRNA technology,
then you're able to multiplex
the delivery of these vaccines.
So that is one approach that
has shown immense early success,
at least in mine so far.
And another approach that
we've also been involved in
is the delivery of a nanoparticle vaccine
that expresses the RBD
of SARS related viruses,
and the RBD of SARS-CoV-2 for example,
actually shares a highly
conserved signature
with a number of different
SARS related viruses.
So we've actually identified
monoclonal antibodies
that are broadly protective against
a number of different
SARS related viruses.
And if you deliver the part of the RBD
that has this broadly protective epitope,
then you can readily induce
broadly protective immunity
in mice.
So what's important and what's
promising is that you have,
at least you have more than one platforms
that can achieve this.
And I think that raises optimism for me.
- Yeah. Well, Akiko,
you know, we've been talking
about vaccine immunity,
but you've been studying a lot about
what goes wrong in the body,
or what just happens in the body
when you get infected
with the coronavirus.
Can you talk a little bit about
what you've been learning
and how is this virus response different
than other coronaviruses, or
just other respiratory viruses?
- Yeah. So one of the first learnings
that we got from studying these patients
was that there this, in the severe cases,
the patients are generally
unable to control the virus well,
especially quick enough.
And what happens is that once
the patients failed to do so,
the virus spreads into the lung
and damages some of the
very delicate tissues
that are required for oxygen,
you know, gas exchange and so on,
and that sort of leading to
this pneumonia phenotype.
And when we study those patients,
what we're finding is that
there is misfiring of the immune response,
that normally we think
of antiviral immunity
mediated by one branch
of the immune response
which is called a type one immunity.
But what we're seeing is that
those patients are also engaging
type two and type three immunity,
which are normally reserved for
fighting parasite infection,
or a fungal infection,
or bacterial infection.
And so what appears to us
is sort of like a misfiring
of the immune response.
They're trying to contain
this virus, you know,
with any tools that we have on hand,
but actually that's resulting
in the pathological outcome
in some of these patients,
because it's not a well-intended
antiviral mechanism.
So, that was the first insight we obtained
from studying the patients in real time.
And later on, we also
studied sex differences
in immune responses that
occur in these patients.
And, you know, as we all know,
male sex is a risk factor
for severe and lethal Covid.
And what we learned is that
in the early phase of the immune response,
women tended to generate
more robust T Cell immunity,
whereas men failed to do so
but they instead engaged
inflammatory responses.
And that may have led to
sort of the lack of control of the virus
that leads to this misfiring
later on that I just mentioned.
So we also learned that
there's a difference
in the way male and female
immune responses are
dealing with the virus.
And that may explain to some extent
some of the, you know,
different risk factors
that we're seeing based on sex.
- There's also,
a lot of people have
been talking more about
long-term effects of viral infections,
and long-term symptoms that you might have
after you've, you know,
recovered from the,
the virus infecting your body,
it's supposedly gone, but you
still have a lot of symptoms,
you know, long Covid.
And I know you've been really involved
in that particular field as well.
So can you talk a little bit about
what you've learned in that arena?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So that's what I'm most
concerned about right now is the,
you know, the lack of
diagnosis, and care, and therapy
that can help people with long Covid.
And so long Covid can happen
in a large fraction of
hospitalized patients
who are discharged alive,
anywhere estimated between
50 to 70% of these people
are still having lingering symptoms
after months of discharge.
And long Covid can also happen
in people who had milder infection,
who were never hospitalized,
but those patients may
also develop long Covid.
The estimated percentages
varies but between five to 30%.
So even if we take a
conservative estimate of 5%,
that's a large number of people,
given how many millions of people
are infected with this virus.
And the latter type
is also, there are more women
in middle-age that's
enriched in that population.
And so we currently have
a couple of hypothesis
we're trying to dissect.
One is that the long Covid can happen
as a result of a potentially,
a viral reservoir,
or some fragments of virus RNA,
or protein that deposits in some tissue
that's causing chronic inflammation.
The other hypothesis
we're pursuing is that
this acute infection causes,
triggers auto immune disease,
which can have long-term consequences,
which involve multiple organ systems.
And so long Covid has at
least 200 different symptoms
that have been reported,
involving like, pretty
much every organ system
you can imagine.
And so we really need to find out
what's going on in these patients
so we can treat them better.
- Are there good treatments at this point?
- No. I wish there were
some good treatments.
I'm not sure if the antivirals
would actually work in these patients.
If it is actually a
persistent virus infection,
that might have some, you
know, beneficial effect.
But we have to remember the long Covid
is likely going to be a
heterogeneous disease.
That it's not one thing that's
causing all these symptoms.
So if we can identify
let's say, cluster of patients that
may be driven by persistent virus,
versus those that are
driven by autoimmunity
or a combination thereof,
we can start to think
about rational therapy
for these people.
But first is really to
identify what's going on
so we can have a better therapy.
And the one thing that
seems to be helping patients
is the vaccination actually.
So there are now reports
demonstrating that,
between 40 to 60% of the long-haulers
that received the vaccine
feel improvement in their symptoms,
whereas about 20% are
getting worse symptoms.
So, that gives us a little bit of idea
as to what kind of triggers
might improve their symptoms
and what we can do to help them.
- So I have a question.
Do you think that that means that
this implicates
persistent virus infection,
or is it causing a downregulation
of a particular immune
response that's detrimental?
- Yeah. So Mark, that's
both possibilities are
currently holding up.
It's, you know,
one possibility is just simply that
the vaccine is inducing really good
immune response that
clears any viral reservoir,
in which case you can have
like a permanent cure.
Some people are getting a
permanent cure from vaccine.
Well, vast majority of
people are not getting that.
They're getting a temporal
improvement in their symptoms,
and it's not that all of
their symptoms go away.
So, that to me tells me that
potentially it's maybe
cytokines or other factors
that's induced by the vaccination,
that's sort of acting
on autoreactive cells
to set down their cytokine production
or potentially antibody production,
but it's not a permanent solution.
So we really need to
understand like what's going on
in these patients so we can
provide a permanent solution.
- Tina, could I comment on that
in terms of related to antivirals
really briefly,
you know, I, and I think
the nice thing for one
of these kinds of forums
is to take us a little bit beyond
and not be afraid to sort of
think and speculate a
little bit because I think
we're also deluded with data
and information every day.
Well, one thing for sure is that
antivirals work best when
there's a viral target.
They don't work at all if
there're direct acting antivirals
that are targeting the virus.
They don't work at all if
there's no virus present,
or if the disease is not viral related.
And I think when, you
know, Remdesivir was used
late in infection because at the time
of course at the height of
the epidemic pre vaccines,
the issue was, can we save people's lives?
Can we get them off ventilators?
And so, it's that fact that it was IV
also encouraged that.
And so I was actually surprised that
it had any impact at all
because all the studies that
had been done in Ralph's lab,
and my lab and others had shown that
you use the drug early and it worked,
you use it late and it doesn't work,
dnd that was true with both
Molnupiravir and Remdesivir.
And I've been thinking about this
in terms of persistent virus infection,
'cause the very first models that I,
the lab I went in and Stanley
Perlman's lab in 1984.
He was working on a model
of viral persistence
and mouse hepatitis virus whereas,
if the dams were immunized
and the infants were infected,
they would not develop
a severe acute disease,
but they would develop persistent disease
that led to chronic demyelinating
encephalitis, right?
So led to demyelination of the brain.
And that was the model
that I was working on,
mouse hepatitis virus for all those years,
which was really an immunological model
of some ways but it also was associated
with long-term persistent infection.
And so I think this is
particularly interesting
because you theoretically
might have a place for
an effective antiviral that decreased,
or that allowed you to
significantly decrease viral load
over a long period of time
that could be taken early.
I hadn't thought of that
actually until this moment,
I'd been thinking prophylactically
or very early in therapy,
but there might be a
role of that associated
with in fact with immunization
because they're not mutually exclusive.
So, that's an interesting idea.
- Yeah. I love that thought.
I mean, what we need is
a good clinical trial.
- Yes.
- You know.
- And I would even say,
Mark, adding to that, you know,
potentially another concept
that could be explored
in conjunction with antivirals
could be Fc region optimized
monoclonal antibodies,
optimized for killing of
virally infected cells.
- Okay. You have to unpack that.
(David and Tina laughing)
what does that mean?
Those words.
Fc what?
- So, antibodies,
so I'm an antibody person.
So monoclonal antibodies have
two different major regions.
They have the antigen binding region.
So the fab region or the Fc region,
which is a part on the antibody
that actually talks to the immune system.
So a number of different recent papers
from different groups
have demonstrated that,
the Fc region is actually required for
not only protection, but you can actually
improve the function of these antibodies
if you make them,
if you modify them in a way that
they can talk to the immune
system a little bit better.
So, that could potentially be
an additive therapy
that you could explore,
not just in the context of
a long Covid for example,
but if you were to maybe
combine that with an antiviral,
so now you have an antiviral
that's targeting the virus
and you have a different type of biologic
that's still anti-viral,
but it's actually engaging
the immune system.
- So that would be different
from the monoclonal antibodies
that we've heard about,
like the ones that are being
used for early treatments.
- Correct. So, even without modifying,
even without optimizing
the part in the antibody that
talks to the immune system,
the antibodies will do
their thing anyways.
So this would, like,
you're correctly surmise,
this would actually include,
for example, the AstraZeneca cocktail,
or the Regeneron cocktail,
or the Bristol-Myers Squibb cocktail.
So this could potentially be,
at least, you know, in this
small proportion of patients
that Akiko mentions that
could have symptoms,
long Covid symptoms that
are driven by the virus,
then this could potentially
be an additional therapy
that could be explored.
- Well. I do want to get
all of your thoughts on
what made this coronavirus
into a pandemic virus?
I mean, I've been writing a long time
about infectious diseases,
and there's been many
different candidates,
you know, mostly different
influenza viruses,
you know, eating influenzas particularly.
And none of them have
really become the pandemic
that was promised.
And then this one just sort
of came out of the blue
and suddenly it was everywhere.
So, what have we learned about this virus?
What makes it so special that
it can be a pandemic virus?
- I think the scary thing is that
nothing makes it so special
from other coronaviruses.
- I think, well, I'll wait
till Mark finishes and jump in.
Go ahead.
- I'll let you, go ahead
Kanta (indistinct).
- To me, the two big differences are,
from all the avian influenza viruses
that had failed to start a
pandemic, or SARS or MERS,
there're two things:
One is that this virus spreads efficiently
from person to person
by the airborne route,
which did not happen with MERS or SARS.
The second really big difference is that
in both SARS and MERS,
everybody who was infected had symptoms,
and with this virus infection,
we have a lot of asymptomatic individuals,
people who don't even
know they're infected,
who are spreading the virus.
So to me, those were
the two game changers.
I first heard about the
person to person transmission
at the very end of January of 2020.
And I was at a flu meeting and I said,
"Oh my goodness, this sounds likes flu.
"This does not sound like SARS at all."
And to me, that is really
what made the difference
in making this virus
able to cause a pandemic.
- I think Kanta and I were
having these conversations
in 2003,
is if SARS escapes, so
we were watching it,
if it escapes into Indian sub-continent,
or the African continent,
or in places where their public health,
we were concerned, there
might be public health,
you know, the control issues
in some places in the world,
war zones, et cetera,
that it would take off.
And certainly you saw
super spreading events
and you saw, we all thought
that that was going to be the one,
But it had Achilles' heel,
and that Achilles' heel
was a required symptomatic,
severe respiratory
infection for transmission.
And I think that that one Achilles' heel,
the other thing is it's efficient.
So there was this issue of
efficiency of transmission
without symptoms.
And second is that it,
really never rose very high
except for the super spreading events.
So those two things really
made it controllable
by public health measures
that haven't been
successful with with Covid.
When I said nothing is special about it,
well, I was, I shouldn't
be cavalier about it.
What I meant was
that we don't understand in coronaviruses
what would make one
different from another.
There's no obvious signal,
except for the potential capacity
of this particular spike protein
to show this kind of dramatic variation.
But when you look at it,
it looks like another family member.
You put them side by side,
and they're going to look
really, really similar.
The number of nucleotide differences
across the replicates gene
is exceptionally small
for they're highly related.
And so what makes it unique?
We don't know and that's what I meant
from the virological perspective,
but I think from the
perspective of differences
we've been worrying
and all of our crying
from the mountain tops
was about, MERS was, this
is transmitted from camels,
there's limited transmission
from human to human,
but if it gains the capacity
for direct respiratory spread,
it was maintaining a 30
to 40% mortality rate
over about an eight year
period of people who got it.
And we were concerned that
this was one that will escape.
And then MERS seems to
have had the bad habits
of both SARS Covid and MERS
Covid, but we do not know why.
And I think that's what
is the important point.
- And I think virologically,
that's true for influenza viruses as well.
We do not yet understand what
makes one influenza virus,
highly transmissible from person
to person and another not.
And that's been an area
of interest and study
because seasonal influenza
viruses transmit very well.
Avian influenza viruses
generally do not, fortunately,
and there are avian influenza viruses
like H5N1 and H7N9
that have very, very
high case fatality rates.
But fortunately do not spread efficiently
from person to person.
So there's been a lot of
interest in the flu community
as well to try to understand
what those determinants
of transmission are,
so that we can then
do a better job at risk assessment
when viruses emerge in, or
cause to zoontic infections,
to know that this one is one to watch
and contain immediately, versus another
that, you know, we could actually
have small outbreaks and still
not be at risk of a pandemic.
- So one thing that I've
written a lot about this year
is the fact that this does seem to be
transmitted through the air,
whereas we didn't use to think
that that was sort of the,
the major route that respiratory
viruses were transmitted,
which to me I guess now it
doesn't really make sense
that they wouldn't be
transmitted through the air,
but is there anything
else that we've learned
that you think is surprising about that.
- So this is an area that is fascinating,
and it's an area where
it's been very clear that
virologists and physicians
speak a very different language
from aerosol biologists.
They both know a lot,
but they spoke a completely
different language,
use different terminology,
different measures.
And so the medical
community basically said
that anything, that it was
all based on particle size,
and that if a particle was
more than five microns in size,
that you emit from the respiratory track
will settle out to the
air within three meters,
within three feet or one meter,
and that's why hospital beds were always
more than a meter apart,
and that any virus particle that stayed,
that was under five microns
could remain suspended in the air,
could travel greater distances,
and was then aerosol transmissible.
Aerosol scientists tell us
that is complete nonsense,
that the particle size
is more like 100 microns,
not five,
and that the size of the particles changes
essentially as soon as you breed them out,
as they dry out, the
particle size changes.
So there's been a, and
I think this last year,
there was a fantastic national
academy of engineering workshop
that brought aerosol
scientists and engineers
together with virologists,
and physicians and
infection control people.
So they're are starting to
break down those barriers
and understand each other.
So I think the science of how viruses
or pathogens are spread through the air
is a absolutely fascinating
field where lots has to happen.
Cause we, I mean, I'm hearing about
built environments and you
know, how do you ventilate?
Because normally we ventilate
in indoor environments
for comfort, not for health.
And so there is a lot that
has to happen in that space,
and I think the public health community
was the slowest to the party.
There was an unwillingness
to use the word airborne transmission,
even though the data was
staring us in our faces.
And so, I think it had to do
with the number of complex issues
such as if you label something
airborne transmissible,
then it changes the type of
personal protective equipment
that you need to then provide to people,
and there was deemed
to be a shortage of it.
So how could you recommend
that if you couldn't supply it?
But I think it is time to sort
of step back from all of that
and look at the data,
talk to our colleagues in other fields,
and really break down some of
these barriers and understand
what is happening and how we
can mitigate some of this.
- Yeah. Well, you mentioned
talking to colleagues
in other fields,
and it seems to me that
science has gotten
incredibly collaborative
across fields and across
the world, you know,
huge numbers of scientists coming together
to work on these problems.
You know, what's you guys' perspective?
Is it, have you seen that,
or are you seeing soloing?
What's going on in terms of
how this pandemic may
be changing research?
- Yeah, I think that's one
of the biggest changes that
I've experienced personally is that,
you know, prior to the pandemic,
we were pretty much doing
things in silos, as scientists,
but with the pandemic,
we've reached out to everyone
who has the expertise
and who's asking the questions
that you're interested in,
not just throughout the school
or throughout the states,
but throughout the world.
So now we have multiple
collaborations all across the globe,
really looking at anything from, you know,
immune pathogenesis, to
vaccine effectiveness,
to, you know, third dose, you know,
what is mix and match,
many, many questions, we can
only address globally together.
And that's been a very
welcoming change for me.
Like this team science
is really the future.
And I think the scientific community,
like academic community
has to catch up with this
in terms of evaluating scientists
The old traditional metrics
about who's the last author,
who's the first author,
this kind of measurements is not conducive
to kind of promoting
this team science effort.
And so that's something
that I think the community,
the scientific academic sort of
environment has to change to accommodate.
- Do you think it will
last beyond the pandemic?
- I hope so. I mean, once
you do the team science,
you can't go backwards.
(Kanta and Akiko laughing)
- I think if,
a lot of,
I agree with the Akiko,
this has been fantastic
and some countries have done it
kind of operationally at a national level.
Like the UK has done some phenominal
clinical trials and clinical evaluation
by forming consortia.
And so it's not just organically.
I mean, it's happened
because the governments
throw money at the problem.
So, I think the money that's
been thrown at the problem
has helped a lot.
And I think my only worry
about the longevity of
this kind of cohesiveness
is if money dries up,
and we again end up
being in a competitive environment again.
So I think that, you
know, funding agencies,
if they can, actually, if they take away
the funding as the reason to compete,
then there'll be able to
have much more collaboration.
- I have seen the rise
and fall and rise and fall
from SARS and MERS.
I think this is different
because it's a pandemic.
I think it's incorporating something.
My question is, are the Akikos
going to stay in the field?
Are they going to stay
interested in virology
as the pressures on it and
become more competitive?
That wasn't targeted for you of course,
but it's because it's so important
to have you in the field,
and that we were a field that
had one or two immunologists
and two or three replication people,
and, you know, three or four
structural biologists maybe
if we were lucky.
And the question is, I think
it's about infrastructure.
It's like bridges. It's
like, do you build them?
And then do you maintain them?
Because I think the answer is correct.
I've had more opportunities
in the last year to talk to
endonuclease and exonuclease biochemists.
People who are developing small molecules
fragment based screening,
novel biochemical
strategies that I ever have.
I've had people reach and want my,
all of my MHV reporter viruses,
because they now want to
look at the cell biology
of coronaviruses in a BSL-2 model.
And they want to try to
understand issues of entry
and so that, you know,
things that I thought
I was going to be putting in the autoclave
at the end of my career,
I'm passing out around the
world and I'm thrilled,
but I'll tell you the most important thing
I think is not for people like
me to establish team science,
it's to have the David Martinez,
and the other people
who come into the field
and who find the capacity to stay.
So what are the issues
associated with that?
Well, there's a couple
major ones that I see.
One is the stability of funding,
and that they can count on that.
Two, is that they find that,
that they can carry that work forward
in a way that's meaningful,
if they weren't doing the hard work.
So, you know, people ask me,
how did you stick with
coronavirus for 36 years?
And my wife wanted to say,
"Well, he's an idiot."
That might've been the answer
but I think the idea is that
the ideas compel you so much,
and you're willing to
fight for those ideas
and go to the fundamental science.
Because if everybody in the world
is looking at the RBD
on the spike protein,
that isn't going to last, right?
It's not going to last
because people have to look at
more fundamental questions,
that kind that David is approaching.
And the final one is,
I think we need, yeah.
We just need young investigators
and we need to support
them through the process
and allow them the time to develop,
and stay in these fields
and make them understand
that it's an area they can thrive in.
That's what matters
Honestly, to me, that's
the issue of continuity
that matters the most.
- Makes me almost feel a little bit guilty
because I was a virologist,
and then I left to become
a science journalist.
- Yeah, well. You may have
left for very positive reasons,
but a lot of people leave
because they don't feel
it's a sustainable career
over the long haul, and that's a problem.
- Yeah.
Erin became a science journalist
doing your internship with us
just at the point where
the pandemic was hitting.
So you're sort of the
perfect person to have,
at a very bad time,
but perfect for us,
which, you know, she
was really instrumental
in helping us properly communicate
the virology about this.
- We have done a terrible job,
we've done a terrible job as scientists
of communicating the terminology
and doing it in a way
that is recognizable,
is understandable to people
and that engages them
and lets them understand it's complex.
And so it's not a contradiction to say,
one day, we're developing a vaccine
to try to prevent infection.
And then we say, well, it
didn't prevent infection,
but boy is it sure accomplishing
the goal of preventing
severe disease and
hospitalization and death.
And that science evolves,
and that it's not static.
- If I could just add a point that
perhaps hasn't been mentioned.
So to echo Mark, I would say
of course, understanding
the fundamental biology
of not just coronaviruses,
but other viruses.
I think it's absolutely critical,
but if I could just add,
maybe an overarching theme
that we need to rethink
and maybe reinvent and redesign is,
how do we change our pandemic
preparedness landscape?
So instead of sitting,
instead of being a sitting duck,
just waiting for a virus to emerge into a
completely naive human population is,
I think we need to start prioritizing
in investing more in pandemic preparedness
on a more global level,
not just pandemic preparedness
in terms of vaccine
and monoclonal antibody
or therapeutic design,
but broad spectrum antivirals,
and even just public health infrastructure
to be able to rapidly
respond to a viral pandemic,
or a pathogen pandemic.
- I mean, to get a little
bit back to the idea that,
I mean, science communication is hard.
All of you have talked in some capacity
to journalists like us
throughout the pandemic.
What are some of the biggest challenges
that you guys have faced
in either communicating
your research or just talking
about the science in general?
- Well, so I use multiple
different platforms
to communicate.
Twitter is the fastest. The moment I type
people can see what I'm talking about.
I've also sort of engaged
with more traditional media,
newspapers, television,
radio shows, and so on.
And I actually decided in
early pandemic to dedicate
a big portion of my life to
doing science communication,
because I think it's important
for scientists to speak,
you know, from experts opinion,
you know, what what's going on,
explaining to the lay public,
what is an immune system?
You know, what does antibody mean?
How does memory work?
All these basic fundamental insights that
many people didn't have prior to pandemic.
Now people are talking about
neutralizing antibody titers,
and RBDs, and, you know,
they have the lingo to be able
to understand and talk about
immune system as well as viruses.
But I think that was important to me
that we as scientists
communicate with the public.
And I think all of us try to do that,
more than ever.
Like I've never been in
contact with so many reporters
prior to pandemic.
Occasionally I would talk
to them about this and that,
but this is just completely
changed the landscape.
And I just hope that more
people will engage in this
because I think the society
needs scientists' voice,
needs our expertise and, you know,
needs people to explain to them, you know,
about what's the future of pandemic?
How do we contain it?
All these issues.
So I think science communication
is a big part of being a scientist.
- And I do think that has going to,
that comes back to what
David was talking about,
about preparing for the
next pandemic, right?
Because at the beginning of all this,
the communication was not amazing.
And so, you know, when
the next pandemic happens,
because it will, hopefully
we'll be more prepared.
- So, I think communication
is absolutely critical
and scientists are often not
taught how to communicate.
So, you know, I was at
CDC and NIH and had,
you know, communications
workshops to attend.
Pardon me, just so you don't
embarrass the government,
but University of Melbourne has one too.
but I think to me probably,
what we could have,
I think the public is
actually has been educated
very much so in the last year and a half,
mRNA rolls off people's tongues,
they all know about
boosting and, you know.
So it is amazing how much
the general public knows of science now,
but I think what we probably
should have communicated better,
and this is, you know,
journalists as well as scientists,
is that we were dealing with
something completely new,
and that the information
was going to change.
And that it is our job to
be open to new information
and to change our thinking
as information evolves.
That simply changing what we're saying
doesn't mean that we are untrustworthy.
That we have to find a way to communicate
that trust should still be maintained
and that we're responding
to new information.
So, unfortunately very often
we are asked to give a definitive answer,
and it's almost phrased-termed
as if, you know,
if you've changed, what you're saying,
that the previous version was false,
and it's rather that we're
fine tuning it as we go.
- I've given answers
sometimes that are provocative
and that the people don't like.
They say,
"How long is this going to last?"
and going,
"I don't think you want to ask me that."
Or they'll say,
"What are you working on now?"
I say,
"SARS-CoV-3."
because we're trying to
prepare for the next virus.
And it's not really being clear what,
the point I'm trying to make, you know,
when I tell people,
people say how long this is going to last,
I said, well, the virus will let us know.
Because I knew, it came
back to some of what Kanta
was saying earlier.
We were talking about earlier
about the virus evolution we don't know.
We just don't know.
And I think one thing that I knew,
but I've learned a new is to be,
is that we need to have about,
one part of science and
about nine parts of humility
around this.
And that if we're in a
position to tell people this,
I start my things off.
I'm going to give you a talk today,
first I'm going to tell you what I know,
what we've worked on and
what our results show.
And I'm going to put those in context.
And then I'm going to
tell you what I think,
and then I'm going to tell
you what I have no idea,
but is my speculation about this.
And I want you to put
those in context because,
the first is data,
the second is my opinion,
and the third is my worry about it.
And so then I think that
I've gotten responses back
from that have been,
I really appreciated that
because it allowed me
to put things in context
of what was really information
and what was opinion,
what was informed opinion,
what was speculation
based on what you know,
and I think that that is,
it also says that in the face
of a virus that is evolving
independent of us, couldn't
care less about us,
that it's going to do what it does.
And I've been shocked and amazed by
it's profound, rapid
evolutionary capacity,
and that we don't know how long it took
OC43 and HKU1, the human
cold coronaviruses.
We don't know how long it took for them
to become the way they became.
It's not going to happen overnight,
and people want to say,
well in a year or so
this is just going to be
a common cold virus.
It might be,
but the statement is nonsense.
And so I think that just
this kind of humility
we haven't had, and our
willingness to say, I don't know,
I don't know. I don't know.
No one's going to keep interviewing us
because they'll stop
because we don't know.
(panelists laughing)
But it's the truth.
It's...
- And I would say, you know,
adding to Mark's point about, you know,
just saying what we don't
know and having humility,
I would add that a strategy
that has certainly worked for me
in terms of communicating with the public
is really trying to communicate
the nuance and science,
and really not speaking in absolute terms.
So just, coming with that
humility of saying, you know,
and just like in real life,
most things most of the
time are never 100 or 0%.
There's always a spectrum.
There are nuances.
And this is one of those things
that is so new for everyone
that we just don't know,
and we're learning as we go.
- Yeah. That is a good point.
Thank you all for those thoughts.
We are coming up on the end of our time.
So I just had one final question,
'cause we wanted to end on a hopeful note
after talking about such a grim, you know,
topic for an hour.
Maybe very briefly, each
of you could just talk
really quick about what has given you hope
over the past two years.
Like one thing that, you know,
is your bright light at
the end of the tunnel.
- Well, what's given me
hope is sort of the future.
As Mark said, I think
supporting and encouraging the
new generation of scientists
is what's giving me hope.
And I see it in my own eyes,
my trainees, as well as people around me,
or young scientists who
are now really engaging in
the science of long Covid,
science of Covid immunity.
It really does give me hope,
and they're so dedicated,
and talented, and driven.
And that to me is the future.
And that's how we fight the next pandemic
is by developing, and growing,
and nurturing the next
generation of scientists.
So that's where I see the light.
- The single most thing
that has given me hope,
is just watch the community,
just come together.
The scientific community come together
with industry partners,
to which we saw the
development of not just,
not one, but three safe
and effective vaccines
in the US alone in less than one year.
So to me, that's been one of the
silver linings of this whole thing
is seeing, you know, if we let
science take the front seat,
then this is what we can achieve together.
- I would add that from my standpoint,
it's the new technologies
and the new team science,
and the sort of breaking down of barriers
domestically and internationally.
And so many people from
many different fields
have entered this field and
really contributed enormously.
And that gives me great hope
that we will see the end of this
and that it will serve us well
with future health threats.
- Well, it gives me hope
this particular virus
is this stunning speed
of development of vaccines and antivirals.
People keep saying, why
is it taking so long?
Well, it didn't.
Even seven years to
develop antivirals I mean,
and the fact that we now
understand the targets,
I think our capacity
to target this is good,
and it's going to serve us well
both from vaccines, antivirals,
understanding of immune response,
all of this is coming together.
It's overwhelming for those
of us who try to keep up
in any area,
and that's why we need
good science communication
to help me find things to read
that I haven't had time to
read the primary literature on.
But I think this,
just the fact of the people
that you have on this
raging across disciplines,
across career stages,
all focused on a common enemy,
but a common area of
science and understanding
that could potentially
lead us into the future
in new models.
So, I think that's the most hopeful thing.
- I think we can all use
some help keeping up with
things that are happening
in the Covid world.
It's all moving so fast.
But again, thank you
all for taking the time
to talk with us.
This has been a fascinating conversation.
I hope you all have
learned as much as we have,
and how much our viewers will.
Viewers, if you want to
learn more about Covid-19
and the coronavirus, you can
always visit our website.
That's science news.org,
and connect with us on social media.
Thanks for joining us.
- Happy anniversary.
(air whooshing)
(upbeat music)